particulièrement touché par la crise
sanitaire les communautés autochtones
doivent s'adapter pour éviter une
propagation massive dans leurs rangs les
membres de la réserve du maria coup en
plein coeur de l'amazonie brésilienne
contrôler rigoureusement les entrées
dans leur village on a des gens qui ont
eu la maladie mais personne n'en est
mort jusqu'à aujourd'hui la pandémie
nous a sérieusement impacté et pas juste
un peu parce que les gens ont accès à
cette ville et il ya un autre pays
voisin qui est la colombie ces gens
viennent de colombie ses proches c'est à
15 minutes
ils viennent ici pour acheter nos
produits du poisson des fruits et
d'autres choses d'autre qu'on frappe est
le problème
les contrôles sont particulièrement
difficiles à mettre en place la ville de
tabac tinga est situé à la frontière
colombienne mais aussi péruvienne la
communauté a donc établi des règles
sanitaires strictes en raison des
nombreux allers et venues une personne
indigènes au sein du maria coup ne peut
pas non plus sortir sans en porter un
masque si elle arrive à la barre hier
sans masque on lui dit de rentrer mettre
un masque pour pouvoir sortir parce
qu'ils ont quitté les terres indigènes
et faire la queue à la banque à la
loterie
ils iront marché elle conseille aussi
aux personnes indigènes en plus les port
du masque le respecter les distances de
sécurité dans les zones densément
peuplées
toujours dans un souci d'anticiper des
contaminations
ces indigènes ont mis en place un
système de soins mélangeant tradition et
médecine occidentale
[Musique]
pour l'instant on prend soin de nous
avec des remèdes traditionnels et des
médicaments occidentaux prescrits par
des infirmiers des médecins selon
l'association des peuples indigènes près
de 6000 membres des communautés
autochtones ont été contaminées par le
kobe de 19 et plus de 300 ont déjà perdu
la vie des suites de la maladie